We just finished walking through a beautiful piazza and there are people enjoying their final drink. I gotta say, your composure during this walk is quite impressive. This might go down as the greatest interview, maybe even podcast of all time on ADSP, the podcast, episode 148, recorded on June 21st, 2023. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Bryce, we record our final episode from the Slovenia 2023 road trip from the streets of Venice at night. And in this episode, we interview Robert Leahy about C++ in FinTech on the way to the Rialto Bridge. That's right, folks, we record another episode walking through the streets of Venice. This one is an absolute blast. Hello, dear listener. So, against our better judgment, we are going to attempt to record another episode
我们刚走过一个美丽的广场，人们正在那里享受他们最后的一杯饮品。我得说，你在这段步行过程中的镇定自若真是令人印象深刻。这或许将成为有史以来最棒的采访，甚至是有史以来最棒的播客，就在 ADSP 播客，第 148 期，录制于 2023 年 6 月 21 日。我叫康纳（Connor），今天与我的联合主持人布莱斯（Bryce）一起，在威尼斯夜晚的街头，录制我们 2023 年斯洛文尼亚公路旅行的最后一期节目。在本期节目中，我们在前往里亚尔托桥的路上采访了罗伯特·利希（Robert Leahy），聊了聊金融科技中的 C++。没错各位，我们录制的又一期节目是在威尼斯街头边走边录的。这一期绝对太棒了。你好，亲爱的听众。所以，出于违背我们理智的决定，我们将尝试录制另一期节目
while wandering the... Oh, God, my feet are wet now. While wandering the streets of Venice. Where are we going, Bryce? We are going to the Rialto Bridge, the famous bridge in Venice. Holy shit. Oh, yeah, the water is...
一边漫步在……哦，天哪，我的脚现在湿了。一边漫步在威尼斯的街道上。我们要去哪里，布莱斯？我们要去里亚尔托桥，威尼斯的著名桥梁。操。哦，对，水是……
The tide's come in, so the water is, the tides come in. So the water is coming up onto the road. And we, we're going to do, this is unheard of, folks. This is ground breaking. Connor, you need to not walk me into puddles. I'm wearing sandals. We've got three feet here.
涨潮了，所以水正在，涨潮了。所以水正漫到路上来。我们要，我们要做的，这真是闻所未闻，各位。这是具有开创性的。康纳，你得别把我带进水坑里。我穿着凉鞋呢。我们这里有三只脚。
We've got three feet. Okay. That's still pretty close to there. Right now Connor is holding the phone and the recorder and trying to navigate us so that he can get more nodes for his little city. Citystripes.com. Citystripes.com. And I'm holding the microphone. And as I said, Connor said at the start of this road trip, that this was something unprecedented, that a tech podcast had never had a road trip component before. I don't think that's true.
我们有三只脚。好吧。离那儿还是挺近的。现在康纳拿着手机和录音机，努力给我们带路，这样他就能为他的小城市获得更多节点。citystripes.com。citystripes.com。我拿着麦克风。正如我所说，康纳在这趟公路旅行刚开始时说过，这是前所未有的，一个科技播客以前从未有过公路旅行环节。我觉得这不是真的。
However, this is now a tech podcast that has a road trip that's going to do a guest interview while walking through Venice. And that certainly has got to be something that's not been done before. Isn't that right, Connor? Definitely not. Also, Bryce fails always at these introductions. It's the Slovenia 2023 Road Trip Podcast. Honestly, this is like the sixth last time we've recorded for the last time. We just had a wonderful dinner at, I don't actually know the name of the restaurant. A wonderful dinner. There were some interesting parts to the dinner. Oh my goodness. Are we going to, we're not going to talk about that. We are. Are we? Yes. All right. And also, listener, you're probably not going to hear from me much because, as Bryce said, we're focused. We walked to dinner tonight and we got 92 nodes on a 6K walk.
然而，现在这是一个拥有公路旅行环节的科技播客，它还将在漫步威尼斯的同时进行嘉宾采访。这绝对是以前没有做过的事情。对吧，康纳？绝对没有。另外，布莱斯总是搞砸这些开场白。这是 2023 年斯洛文尼亚公路旅行播客。老实说，这就像是我们最后一次录音的倒数第六次。我们刚在一家，我其实不知道名字的餐厅吃了顿美餐。一顿美餐。晚餐有一些有趣的插曲。哦天哪。我们要，我们不打算聊那个。我们要聊的。是吗？对。好吧。而且，听众朋友们，你们可能不会听到我多说什么，因为正如布莱斯所说，我们很专心。我们今晚步行去吃晚饭，在 6 公里的步行中获得了 92 个节点。
That's unheard of. The per kilometer node rate here in Venice is off the charts. And actually, if you heard last episode, I predicted that. I predicted that this would be the case. There's a pedal car in front of me. I'm very excited. So you're probably not going to hear from me much because I'm going to be navigating. You're going to be hearing from our guest, Rob, who we're going to introduce.
这简直闻所未闻。威尼斯这里的每公里节点率简直爆表。事实上，如果你听了上一期节目，我预言过这一点。我预言会是这样。我面前有一辆脚踏车。我很兴奋。所以你可能不会听到我多说什么，因为我要负责导航。你们将听到我们的嘉宾罗布（Rob）的声音，我们马上要介绍他。
I assume Bryce is going to introduce at some point. And I actually don't know what we're going to talk about first. Are we talking about the dinner? Are we talking about... Hi. Let's introduce Rob. Let's introduce Rob. Hi, Rob. Would you like to introduce yourself? Hello. My name is Robert Leahy. I live in New York, and I grew up in Canada. And I'm a member of the ISO C++ Committee,
我想布莱斯会在某个时候介绍他。其实我不知道我们首先要聊什么。我们在聊晚餐吗？我们在聊……嗨。让我们介绍一下罗布。让我们介绍一下罗布。嗨，罗布。你想自我介绍一下吗？你好。我叫罗伯特·利希（Robert Leahy）。我住在纽约，在加拿大长大。我是 ISO C++ 委员会的成员，
and I sit in Lug under the watchful eyes of Bryce here. Well, thank you, Rob. All right, what are we talking about today? Well, let's introduce Rob a little bit more. Yeah, like, where do you... You said you're from Canada. You said you're living in New York now. You're an ISO member.
我在布莱斯的密切关注下参加 Lug 会议。嗯，谢谢你，罗布。好了，我们今天聊点什么？好吧，让我们多介绍一点罗布吧。对，比如，你从哪……你说你来自加拿大。你说你现在住在纽约。你是一名 ISO 成员。
Why did you join the c++ committee i mean going i was interested in c++ from the time that i was in university and you know you read secondhand about all the things that go on in the committee and how the language is evolving and when i got into learning about it c++ 11 was new and then 14 came out and so all that seemed very new and exciting and it was right there on the the front of my mind and then when i moved to new y York and I started working in the community and and going to CBPCon I figured this is the next thing I should do and one morning I was at the office very early as I want to do when a co-worker of mine who lives upstate came in unusually early for him and he just looked at me and said I'm not going to Belfast you should go and this was with
你为什么加入 C++ 委员会？我的意思是，从大学时代起我就对 C++ 感兴趣，你知道的，你通过二手消息了解委员会里发生的一切以及语言是如何演变的，当我开始学习它时，C++11 还是崭新的，然后 14 就发布了，所以所有这些看起来都非常新鲜和令人兴奋，它就在我脑海中最显眼的地方。然后当我搬到纽约，开始在社区工作并去参加 CppCon 时，我想这是我应该做的下一件事。一天早晨，我在办公室非常早，就像我习惯做的那样，一个住在上州（Upstate）的同事来得很早，这对他来说很不寻常，他看着我说：“我不去贝尔法斯特了，你应该去。”这只有
10 days of notice and at the time I was the kind of person who didn't travel very well. So it was all a whirlwind, but it was worth it in the end. So what exactly do you do, like work-wise? So I work in financial technology, and that's pretty much all I've ever done in the C++ universe. Before that, I'm very ashamed to say that I wrote PHP code to put myself through university. Was that a PHP hack or a PHP piece? No, no hack at all. Just straight PHP.
10 天的通知期。当时我是那种很不擅长旅行的人。所以这一切都像是一场旋风，但最终是值得的。那么你到底是做什么的，就工作而言？我从事金融科技工作，在 C++ 领域基本上我一直都在做这个。在此之前，我很不好意思地说，我写过 PHP 代码来赚取大学学费。那是 PHP 恶搞还是 PHP 作品？不，一点也不是恶搞。就是纯粹的 PHP。
I couldn't even convince the boss I had at the time to use any kind of framework. So we kind of like rolled our own and he insisted that there needed to be HTML in the mix or he couldn't understand the code. And it was very messy, but it paid the bills and I managed to graduate with no student loans. So I guess I'm obligated to thank PHP for that,
我甚至无法说服当时的Boss使用任何框架。所以我们有点像是自己搞了一套，他坚持认为其中必须包含 HTML，否则他就看不懂代码。这非常混乱，但它付清了账单，我设法在没有助学贷款的情况下毕业了。所以我想我不得不为此感谢 PHP，
very unfortunately. PHP, check out plrank.com it's a top 10 language baby people hate on it but it's popular what can we say? I also very early in my programming career did write some PHP I was very bad at it. I'm just going to go out there and say that numbers can't necessarily speak to quality you know like I'm going to pick quality over quantity quantity um every time and now that we've had this aside about php and my emotions have gotten a bit boiled up i've forgotten what we're even talking about so okay we're talking about what you do okay so you work in financial
非常不幸的是。PHP，去看看 plrank.com，它是一门前 10 语言，宝贝。人们讨厌它，但它很受欢迎，我们能说什么呢？我在编程生涯的早期也写过一些 PHP，我在这方面很糟糕。我要直言不讳地说，数字不一定能说明质量，你知道，比如我每次都会选择质量而不是数量，数量。既然我们已经聊了关于 PHP 的题外话，而且我的情绪有点激动，我都忘了我们刚才在聊什么了。好吧，我们在聊你是做什么的。好吧，所以你从事金融
technology and i feel like we we don't hear a lot from i'm going to take this we don't hear a lot from people in the fintech sector because a lot of people in the fintech sector it is difficult for them to talk about uh their work uh in particular people who are like you know hft companies and stuff like that they tend to not give talk conference talks but like what what specifically what sort of software do you write and like what what are the sort of things that you deal with um in the code that you work with So when I first started working for the fintech startup I was working at, there was a lot of bread and butter feed handler code. And anyone who works in HFT and is in that universe that you just alluded to, Bryce, will understand that you're just basically trying to understand the protocol the exchange sends you
科技，我觉得我们——我要接过来——我们很少听到来自金融科技行业的人的声音，因为金融科技行业的很多人，他们很难谈论他们的工作，特别是像你们知道的高频交易（HFT）公司之类的人，他们往往不做会议演讲，但是——但是具体来说，你写什么样的软件，在你处理的代码中你主要处理哪些事情？当我刚开始为我工作的那家金融科技初创公司工作时，有大量最基础的行情接入（feed handler）代码。任何在 HFT 工作并处于你刚刚提到的那个领域的人，布莱斯，都会明白，你基本上只是在试图理解交易所发送给你的协议，
and the exchanges are bad at documentation. And then to the degree to which they're bad at documentation, they're even worse at implementing their own documentation. So there's a lot of tribal knowledge and you're writing C++ code and you're having people look over your shoulder and hand ring about performance. But that's really the entry level to the financial technology industry. And the company I worked for, we weren't doing trading. So we were trying to appeal to all the stakeholders in finance and programming, HFT, etc. And so my experience with financial technology programming has taken me on a tour
而交易所不善于编写文档。并且，他们编写文档有多烂，他们在实现自己的文档时就有多糟糕。所以有很多隐性知识（tribal knowledge），你在写 C++ 代码，有人站在你身后对性能忧心忡忡。但这确实是金融科技行业的入门水平。我工作的公司不涉及交易。所以我们试图吸引金融和编程领域的所有利益相关者、HFT 等等。因此，我对金融科技编程的体验带我进行了一次巡礼，
that's included things like writing feed handlers, writing drop copy on top of custom in-house fix engines, and then writing that fix engine to writing a time series database that, you know, eventually got put on ice, but occupied three years of my professional time. And, you know, I ended up getting a patent out of, so I'm okay with that. So that's, did that get replaced by a external time series DB or why did that get shelved? So my company, um, when, when, you know, I worked for a startup, not everybody may know, what is a time series database? So a time series database is a database engine whose primary method of querying and storing data is based on when it occurs in time. So the data it stores is a time series where every item is keyed by exactly one key.
其中包括编写行情接入程序、在自定义内部 FIX 引擎之上编写订单回报（drop copy）程序，然后从编写该 FIX 引擎转向编写一个时序数据库（time series database），这个数据库最终被搁置了，但占去了我三年的职业生涯。而且，你知道，我最终从中获得了一个专利，所以我对此挺满意。那么，那个被一个外部的时序数据库取代了吗，还是为什么被搁置了？所以我的公司，当，当，你知道的，我是一家初创公司，可能不是每个人都知道，什么是时序数据库？所以时序数据库是一个数据库引擎，其查询和存储数据的主要方法基于数据发生的时间。因此它存储的数据是一个时间序列，其中每个项目都由且仅由一个键进行索引。
In our case, it was two keys, which is one of the novel things that we added because we had a product and a time. But the primary value add is that everything is keyed on a time. And if you want all the data between two times, you can very easily get it. The database is built from the ground up to retrieve that extremely quickly. And in finance, it's very important because one of the queries that people want to perform very often in finance is to understand what happened between these two times of interest. And a time series database from the ground up is built to do exactly that. And to answer the question that Connor just asked about, you know, why this thing was wound down, really, it's because the company that I was working for that was producing this database,
在我们的案例中，是两个键，这是我们添加的创新点之一，因为我们有一个产品和一个时间。但主要的附加价值是所有内容都以时间为键。如果你想要两个时间之间的所有数据，你可以非常容易地获取它。该数据库从底层开始构建，旨在以极高的速度检索这些数据。在金融领域这非常重要，因为金融领域人们经常想要执行的查询之一，是了解这两个感兴趣的时间之间发生了什么。而时序数据库从底层开始就是为了做到这一点而构建的。为了回答康纳刚才提出的关于“为什么这个东西被停掉了”的问题，实际上，是因为我所工作的、生产这个数据库的公司，
that got the patent on it, that made it into an ecosystem, we got acquired. And, you know, when you get acquired, a lot of priorities get reshuffled. You're trying to integrate with a new business. And this is one of the things that got put on ice as we tried to integrate with a new company, which is still an effort that's ongoing. That's one of the reasons why a lot of my old talks and appearances are under May Street, and the new ones are under the London Stock Exchange Group. Very interesting. So, you got an idea? Oh, no, I was focusing on where we're going. I was just, I mean, we, Bryce and I,
获得了该专利的公司，将其融入一个生态系统的公司，我们被收购了。而且，你知道，当你被收购时，很多优先级都会被重新洗牌。你正试图与一个新业务进行整合。在我们试图与新公司整合的过程中，这个项目被搁置了，而这项整合工作目前仍在进行中。这就是为什么我的许多旧演讲和公开露面都是在 May Street 名义下，而新的演讲则是在伦敦证券交易所集团（London Stock Exchange Group）名义下。非常有趣。所以，你有一个想法？哦，不，我当时正专注于我们要去的地方。我只是，我是说，我们，布莱斯和我，
we haven't ever talked about this on the podcast, but we do personally have an interest in time series DB. Here's actually a random question. Having worked in the financial space, are you familiar with the Q and KDB plus technologies? The answer probably is no, but maybe a small chance I might be yes. So in terms of familiarity, like personal experience with Q and KDB, and I think there's also K in the mix there. The answer to that is no personal familiarity, but we have had clients because, you know, as a startup, we try to dabble in a lot of areas. We try to get traction in a lot of areas. One of the areas we're getting traction is because one of our big focuses was on lossless packet capture and the value add on top of that. We were looking at putting stuff in KDB databases using all these languages.
我们以前从未在播客中谈论过这个，但我们个人确实对时序数据库很感兴趣。这里其实有一个随性的问题。在金融领域工作过，你熟悉 Q 和 KDB+ 技术吗？答案可能是否定的，但也可能有一点点肯定是。所以在熟悉程度方面，比如对 Q 和 KDB 的个人经验，我想其中还有 K。答案是没有个人熟悉度，但我们确实有客户，因为，你知道，作为一家初创公司，我们试图涉足很多领域。我们试图在很多领域获得牵引力。我们获得牵引力的领域之一，是因为我们的重大重点之一是无损数据包捕获以及在此基础上的附加价值。我们一直在考虑使用所有这些语言将数据放入 KDB 数据库中。
And I never got direct exposure to that except to have people vent at me that it was not a great technology in their opinion. And now I can't vouch for the veracity of their opinion or whether it's grounded in truth. But that was the hearsay that I got. And I've heard pushback against that when I've gone over drinks with people and gossip with them. And as I said, I have no personal way of corroborating that. But that's the hearsay, at least within the company that I work for. Are you able to state, this is spicy stuff, because my other podcast, Arraycast, is representing that community. Not Q specifically, but we do have a Q representative. Are you able to say, not by name, the people, obviously, because we never want to call out people,
我从未直接接触过它，除了有人向我抱怨说，在他们看来，这不是一项伟大的技术。现在我无法保证他们意见的真实性，也无法保证它是否有事实根据。但这就是我听到的道听途说。当我跟人们一起喝酒并和他们八卦时，我听到过对它的反对意见。正如我所说，我没有个人的方式来证实这一点。但这就是道听途说，至少在我工作的公司内部是这样。你能说出——这可是个辛辣的话题，因为我的另一个播客 ArrayCast 代表了那个社区。不是专门指 Q，但我们确实有一个 Q 的代表。你能说出——当然不能说出具体的人名，因为我们永远不想点名某个人——
but are folks from a certain company or a certain sub-industry of fintech that have said that? Or is it just sort of a smorgasbord? I mean, we want the spicy. We love spicy content. of fintech that have said that or is it just sort of a smorgasbord smorgasbord i mean i just it's uh we want the spicy we love spicy content hot takes are what drive ratings so i think the people who have said this to me in the past were people who are who are coming at that platform from an outside engineering perspective like they kind of came in with engineering first principles in mind and they didn't have a lot of the context around the development and emergence of KDB and its associated languages loaded into their brain. And so maybe some of those design decisions made sense to the stakeholders in the area, but for someone looking in, it just looked
但是说这话的人来自某家公司或金融科技的某个子行业吗？还是只是一种大杂烩？我的意思是，我们想要辛辣的。我们喜欢辛辣的内容。金融科技的哪些人说过这话，还是说这只是大杂烩？大杂烩，我的意思是，这，我们想要辛辣的。我们喜欢辛辣的内容。热门观点是推动收视率的关键因素，所以我认为过去对我说这话的人，是从外部工程的角度来看待那个平台的——他们有点带着工程第一性原理进入该领域，而且他们的大脑中没有加载很多围绕 KDB 及其相关语言的发展和出现的背景。所以也许其中一些设计决策对该领域的利益相关者来说是有意义的，但对于旁观者来说，它看起来只是一团糟。
like a mess. And so I ended up with basically a stream of complaints about it washing over me. And that formed my opinion of it in a way that, as I admitted before, isn't informed by my own firsthand experience, but just sort of by hearsay, which as I admitted before, isn't informed by my own first-hand experience, but just sort of by hearsay, which, as I said before, can be very lossy. But that's my impression, is my impression is people came in with expectations they had from other areas of software engineering. They came into this very specific space where I think there's only one contender. They were immersing themselves in a lot of tribal knowledge they didn't quite understand, and they had nothing but complaints about it.
所以我最终基本上听到了源源不断的抱怨声。这在某种程度上形成了我的看法，正如我之前承认的那样，这不是由我自己的第一手经验决定的，而只是通过道听途说，正如我之前承认的那样，这不是由我自己的第一手经验决定的，而只是通过道听途说，正如我之前所说，道听途说是非常容易失真的。但这就是我的印象，我的印象是人们带着他们从软件工程其他领域获得的期望来到这里。他们来到了这个非常特定的领域，我认为这里只有一个竞争者。他们沉浸在很多他们并不完全理解的隐性知识中，对此除了抱怨别无他物。
And I think a lot of that, combined with the novelty of our use case, led to us designing our own time series database, because I think we did look at KDB, and it was decided that it wasn't fit for the purpose that we had particularly. Yeah, so it's something to be implicit in this conversation that Rob and I have been having back and forth. But for folks that haven't picked up on it, KDB Plus is a time series database
我认为这很大程度上，加上我们用例的新颖性，导致我们设计了自己的时序数据库，因为我认为我们确实考察过 KDB，并断定它特别不适合我们的目的。是的，所以罗布和我一直在来回讨论的对话中隐含着一件事。但对于没有领会到这一点的听众来说，KDB+ 是一个时序数据库，
that is, to a certain extent, quite popular across certain firms in the financial space, which is why I asked about it. Anyways, very interesting. We were going to have to have more guests with time series DB experience to get... To get to the bottom of this.
在某种程度上，它在金融领域的某些公司中相当受欢迎，这就是我问起它的原因。无论如何，非常有趣。我们将来得邀请更多有时序数据库经验的嘉宾来……来弄清事情的真相。
Yeah, because the language, the executable, was sold for $100 million, and it is, by the people that hold it in high regards, it is highly regarded. But that's the thing. I think there are mixed opinions. You should explain that it is associated with a particular array programming language. Yeah, so when Rob mentioned that Q was sort of in the mix, so go check out, I will link it in the show notes,
对，因为这门语言，这个可执行文件，曾以 1 亿美元的价格售出，而且在那些对它推崇备至的人看来，它备受推崇。但这就是问题所在。我认为大家的看法不一。你应该解释一下它与一种特定的数组编程语言有关。是的，所以当罗布提到 Q 某种程度上参与其中时，去看看——我会在节目笔记中链接它——
an episode from ArrayCast where we talk about the history of K. And actually, we did a little history of K. We did it because it was really fascinating. Yeah. So the short version, though, is that there's been K0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, and 9 is the latest, which is Shaq DDB. But K4 was spun into a company called KX and was sold for $100 million. But one of the caveats was that K is an ASCII language. It only uses ASCII symbols. And the people that were buying the executable first derivatives, which is a company based in Ireland, did not want to use an ASCII-based language that is just kind of line noise, according to them.
ArrayCast 的一期节目，我们在其中讨论了 K 的历史。事实上，我们做了一点关于 K 的历史。我们这样做是因为它真的很吸引人。是的。不过简短的版本是，有过 K0、1、2、3、4、5、6、7，而最新的是 Shaq DDB。但 K4 被剥离成了一家名为 KX 的公司，并以 1 亿美元的价格售出。但其中一个条件是 K 是一种 ASCII 语言。它只使用 ASCII 符号。而购买该可执行文件的衍生品公司（这是一家总部位于爱尔兰的公司）不想使用一种纯粹由 ASCII 组成的、依他们看就像是行噪声（line noise）的语言。
So they asked for a wordified version. And Q is that wordified version. They basically, instead of, you know, writing a slash for a reduction, which is what that is in the K language. Did you really mean ASCII symbols? Yeah. Every function is a single ASCII character in the K language. But in Q...
所以他们要求提供一个单词化的版本。而 Q 就是那个单词化的版本。他们基本上，不用，你知道的，用斜杠表示化简（reduction），这在 K 语言中就是那个意思。你真的是指 ASCII 符号吗？是的。在 K 语言中，每个函数都是一个单 ASCII 字符。但在 Q 中……
A single ASCII character. Yes. So like But in Q... A single ASCII character. Yes. So like exclamation mark, plus, slash, minus, etc. And, you know, comma. Everything maps to a function. And in Q, instead of using a single ASCII character, they added a word for every ASCII character. So now instead of being able to say plus slash with two ASCII characters,
一个 ASCII 字符。是的。比如……但在 Q 中……一个 ASCII 字符。是的。比如感叹号、加号、斜杠、减号等。还有，你知道的，逗号。一切都映射到一个函数。在 Q 中，他们没有使用单个 ASCII 字符，而是为每个 ASCII 字符添加了一个单词。所以现在，不再是说用两个 ASCII 字符表示加号斜杠，
you would say, I'm actually not sure if they added plus as a keyword for the plus symbol, because I think plus is pretty well known by everyone, but you would say plus over. Technically, I think it's parentheses plus, parentheses over. But anyways, the diesel is on the ladder. And they also added shortcut conveniences, so you would never actually spell parentheses plus parentheses over. You would spell some. And anyways, point is, keywords were added to K. That became Q.
你会说——其实我不太确定他们是否将“plus”添加为加号符号的关键字，因为我觉得每个人都很清楚“plus”是什么，但你会说 plus over。技术上讲，我认为它是圆括号 plus，圆括号 over。不管怎样，柴油机在梯子上。他们还添加了快捷便利功能，所以你实际上永远不会拼写出圆括号 plus 圆括号 over。你会拼写 sum。不管怎样，重点是，关键字被添加到了 K 中。这就变成了 Q。
That's what they sold. Why am I so out of breath? So Connor is a little bit out of breath because we just walked up a bridge to cross the Grand Canal of Venice because we are now headed towards the other bridge. Wait, how do you know that's the Grand Canal of Venice, because we are now headed towards the other bridge. Wait, how do you know that's the Grand Canal? Because that's what Rob told me earlier. So, okay, back to a different topic from earlier.
这就是他们卖出的东西。为什么我这么喘不上气？所以康纳有点喘不上气，因为我们刚刚爬上一座桥，穿过了威尼斯大运河，因为我们现在正朝另一座桥走去。等等，你怎么知道那是威尼斯大运河，因为我们现在正朝另一座桥走去。等等，你怎么知道那是大运河？因为罗布刚才就是这么告诉我的。所以，好吧，回到刚才的另一个话题。
All right, back to talking to Rob. What is a feed handler? I mean, before we end the discussion about KDB, I was reloading the context. This was from several years ago into my mind, and one of the things that Bear's pointing out is the use case that we had that we were trying to fit KDB into was very particular. We were trying to, like, shove a lot of market data into it and then process a lot of market data out. And I think that a lot of the K queries were too pre-canned and involved a lot of caching things in memory, if I remember correctly, whereas we were looking for a more stream-based approach. And that may have been where some of the friction came from. Again, I'm not 100% certain of all the details because I didn't do that exploration.
好的，回到与罗布的对话。什么是行情接入程序（feed handler）？在结束关于 KDB 的讨论之前，我正在脑海中重新加载上下文。这是几年前的事了，值得指出的事情之一是，我们试图将 KDB 切入的用例非常特殊。我们试图将大量市场数据塞进去，然后通过查询处理出大量市场数据。而且我认为许多 K 查询过于刻板，涉及很多在内存中缓存的事情，如果我没记错的话，而我们正在寻找一种更基于流的方法。这可能就是一些摩擦的来源。同样，我并不是 100% 确定所有细节，因为那不是我做的探索。
I just know we did not find it fit for purpose, which is something that a lot of people I've gossiped with in the financial technology industry have found very interesting indeed because a lot of them are very interested in KDB and use it as their one and only tool for a lot of these jobs. Sorry, Bryce, back to you. What was your question? We're going to have to have FinTech Watch now. We're going to have to bring people, because we don't, I mean, it's hard to get people from hedge funds
我只知道我们发现它不符合我们的目的，这让很多我在金融科技行业中八卦过的人觉得非常有趣，因为他们中的很多人对 KDB 非常感兴趣，并将其用作完成许多这类工作的唯一工具。抱歉，布莱斯，回到你这里。你的问题是什么？我们现在得搞一个“金融科技观察”（FinTech Watch）。我们得把人们请来，因为我们——我是说，很难请到来自对冲基金
and HFT firms on, but clearly Rob's chatting with us because he doesn't work for a proprietary trading desk and doesn't have to worry about getting his hand slapped. There's probably more of these folks out there that we could be talking to. So, FinTech Watch, ADSP listeners, you heard it here first. We're going to get more
和 HFT 公司的嘉宾，但很显然罗布在跟我们聊天，因为他不是为自营交易台工作的，也不用担心挨板子。外面可能还有更多这样的人，我们可以跟他们谈谈。所以，“金融科技观察”，ADSP 的听众们，你们在这里听到了第一手消息。我们要请更多
folks like Rob on, or maybe Rob is just going to be the only guy we talk to in the FinTech space, and we're going to have him back as a regular podcast guest. What is a feed handler? So the way that a lot of financial exchanges work, and when I say a lot of financial exchanges, one of the things that's coming out of the expansion of my company is the fact that a lot of this knowledge that I have is very strongly America-centric and perhaps Europe-centric. So the markets in America and Europe function by broadcasting UDP multicast data to recipients who receive it,
像罗布这样的人来，或者也许罗布将成为我们在金融科技领域交谈的唯一一个人，我们要让他回归做我们的常驻播客嘉宾。什么是行情接入程序？所以很多金融交易所的工作方式——当我说是很多金融交易所时，随着我公司的扩张，我所了解的这些知识的一个特点是，它非常强烈地以美国为中心，也许还有欧洲为中心。因此，美国和欧洲的市场运作方式是向接收者广播 UDP 多播（multicast）数据，
and a feed handler would be something that takes that data off the wire, parses it, and makes sense of it in some way, like provides you some kind of structured data you can interact with in C++ or your language of choice that allows you to actually make sense of the data as something other than zeros and ones. The degree to which you... It's always UDP? Right.
而行情接入程序就是这样一种东西：它从网络上获取该数据，对其进行解析，并以某种方式理解它，比如为你提供某种结构化数据，你可以在 C++ 或你选择的语言中与之交互，从而真正将数据理解为不仅仅是零和一的东西。你理解的程度……这总是 UDP 吗？没错。
And so that's what I was alluding to when I said that a lot of this knowledge that I have from working for this startup is centered around America and Europe. In America and Europe, primarily, the data is transmitted via UDP. Throughout the rest of the world, for example, Asia and the Middle East, it's a mix, right? A lot of the exchanges do transmit the data via UDP, but others choose to do so via TCP Unicast, which calls into question a lot of the software patterns that we use for handling this market data because they still have market data in the sense that we think of market data, right? A stream of updates from the market, status updates, trades, orders, levels, etc. But they don't disseminate
这就是我刚才暗示的意思，当我谈到我从这家初创公司工作获得的许多知识都以美国和欧洲为中心时。在美国和欧洲，主要地，数据是通过 UDP 传输的。而在世界其他地方，例如亚洲和中东，情况则参半，对吧？许多交易所确实通过 UDP 传输数据，但其他交易所选择通过 TCP 单播（unicast）进行传输，这就对我们用于处理这些市场数据的许多软件模式提出了质疑，因为他们仍然拥有我们认为的市场市场数据（行情）——来自市场的更新流、状态更新、交易、订单、盘口（levels）等。但他们不会通过多播通道分发
that information over a multicast channel. Instead, you have to connect up, authenticate, subscribe to the data you're interested in, which may be some or all of it, and then receive it on a unicast channel, which is something that I think that a lot of firms that operate primarily in America and Europe aren't quite used to. And we're going through a little bit of a technical cultural shock in that area. Interesting. So you alluded to this a little bit earlier, that all these various different feeds, that they have different formats and protocols, and it sort of sounded a little bit like it may have been like the Wild West.
该信息。相反，你必须连接、进行身份验证、订阅你感兴趣的数据（可能是部分或全部数据），然后在单播通道上接收它，我认为这对于主要在美国和欧洲运营的许多公司来说并不是很习惯。我们在该领域经历了一点技术文化冲击。有趣的是。所以你刚才稍微提到了这一点，所有这些各种各样的行情源，它们具有不同的格式和协议，听起来有点像蛮荒西部。
To what degree are there standards or specifications for all this financial data? And is there an industry consortium or something that writes out that specification? Or is it just like a certain company says this is what they're going to do? How does that work? I mean, since I've been developing this proprietary time series database that's recently been put on ice, I've been taken a little bit out of that world. So I was much more in that world approximately three years or so ago when I had my hands dirty in the feed handler world. But that was also before the startup I worked for kind of took off and then got acquired by a large multinational and we got exposure to this range of markets. What I would say is that to the degree to which there's standardization,
在多大程度上存在针对所有这些金融数据的标准或规范？是否有行业财团或类似机构编写该规范？还是说只是一家公司说这就是他们要做的？这通常是怎么运作的？我的意思是，自从我一直在开发这个最近被搁置的专有时间序列数据库以来，我有点脱离了那个世界。所以大约三年前，当我亲手接触行情接入程序的世界时，我更多地身处那个世界。但这也是在我工作的初创公司腾飞并被一家大型跨国公司收购之前，我们才接触到了这一系列市场。我想说的是，就标准化程度而言，
there kind of isn't standardization. Like a of exchanges and by a lot i don't mean necessarily even a double digit percentage but a lot of them will like take nasdaq's technical specification and use some version of them but they may be mutually unintelligible they may use nasdaq's framing protocol but then the payload may be different for example like um mold and its equivalent which i can't uh call to memory right now walking around the streets of venice are fairly common we should say that it is almost 11 p.m. local time Venice, the dark streets of Venice, and we're recording this podcast live. We're walking to the Rialto Bridge. I'm so disappointed we didn't interview Christian and Damien like this. This is groundbreaking stuff, folks. I'm
可以说是根本没有标准化。就像很多交易所——这里说的很多甚至不一定是两位数的百分比——但很多交易所会采用纳斯达克的的技术规范并使用其中的某个版本，但它们可能是互不相通的，它们可能会使用纳斯达克的成帧协议，但有效负载可能不同，例如……嗯，mold 以及与其等效的我目前记不起来的东西，漫步在威尼斯街头，这些都挺常见的。我们应该说现在当地时间将近晚上 11 点，威尼斯，威尼斯黑暗的街道，我们正在现场录制这个播客。我们正走去里亚尔托桥。我很遗憾我们没有像这样采访克里斯蒂安（Christian）和达米安（Damien）。这可是开创性的东西，各位。我正在
looking at the audio quality. This is coming through crystal clear. The listener is going to get to hear this conversation. We're walking, we're talking. This is a high quality. I'm thinking to myself, I can't believe this, the quality of this interview. I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, well, we're almost hit some people, but that's okay. They walked around us. Oh, look, a squirrel. I'm just, I'm just, I can't, I can't believe it, Rob. This is fantastic. Keep going. And, and, you know, Connor and I are can't, I can't believe it, Rob. This is fantastic. Keep going. And, and, you know, Connor and I are both Canadian, at least, you know, culturally. And so I only regret that you can't hear him say sorry and me say, uh, more often as we almost run into people with a wire and a microphone, we just finished walking through a beautiful Piazza and there are people enjoying their, their final drink. So it's not really the kind of environment in which you
看音频质量。这听起来非常清晰。听众将能听到这段对话。我们在走，我们在聊。这是一个高质量的。我心想，我真不敢相信，这次采访的质量。我，我，我，我，好吧，我们差点撞到人，但没关系。他们绕过了我们。哦，看，一只松鼠。我只是，我只是，我简直不敢相信，罗布。这太棒了。继续。而且，你知道，康纳和我都是加拿大人，至少，你知道的，在文化上。所以我唯一的遗憾是，当我们的电线和麦克风差点撞到人时，你们听不到他说“抱歉”和我说“呃”的次数更多一些。我们刚走过一个美丽的广场，人们在那里享受着他们最后的一杯饮品。所以这其实不是那种你会把注意力高度集中在谈论的技术细节上的环境。不过你表现得太棒了。你太棒了，罗布。
focus the most on the technical aspects of what you're talking about. You're crushing it, though. You're crushing it, Rob. People are going to be falling off their seats. They're not going to believe that this was, I mean, I think they'll hear some Italian voices passing us every once in a while. And that's the only thing that'll keep people believing that we're actually recording this podcast live, walking, talking.
人们会惊掉下巴的。他们不会相信这——我的意思是，我想他们会偶尔听到一些意大利语声音从我们身旁飘过。这是唯一能让人相信我们确实是在现场录制这个播客、边走边聊的东西。
It's a new format. We're changing the game, Bryce. We're changing the game here on ADSP the podcast live from the dark streets of Italy at 11 p.m. at night. Look at that. You know what? You heard those voices in the background. Those were some tourists slash Italians enjoying. Also, at some point, we're getting gelato.
这是一种新格式。我们在改变游戏规则，布莱斯。我们在 ADSP 播客中改变游戏规则，现场直播于晚上 11 点意大利黑暗的街道。看那个。你知道吗？你听到了背景中的那些声音。那是游客兼意大利人在享受生活。另外，在某个时候我们要去吃意式冰淇淋。
I have the perfect beef to pick with Rob. And earlier, Connor and I talked about how this podcast, which is called the Algorithms plus Data Structures equals Programs podcast, the name of the book. We talked about how we don't really talk about data structures that much in this podcast because Connor and I are kind of anti-data structure people. We're just very pro-algorithm. We're very pro-algorithm. Sure. But there is a particular data structure that has truly confounded me. And it is the proposed Stood Hive. And I think Rob would be a great person here to ask about Hive because when we recently, and I should explain, Stood Hive is the thing that's been proposed for the standards
我对罗布有一个完美的异议（beef to pick）。早些时候，康纳和我讨论了这个播客，它被称为“算法加数据结构等于程序”播客，也就是那本书的名字。我们讨论了为什么我们在本播客中实际上并没有讨论那么多数据结构，因为康纳和我有点反数据结构倾向。我们非常支持算法。我们非常支持算法。当然。但有一个特定的数据结构确实让我感到困惑。这就是提出的 Stood Hive。我认为罗布在这里是个很好的人选，可以向他询问关于 Hive 的问题，因为当我们最近——我应该解释一下，Stood Hive 是提议给标准委员会的东西。
committee. And then I'm going to let Rob explain what it is. But it's a thing that I have been unable to understand its purpose, and I think Rob was initially felt that way, but then over the course of last week at the Varna Committee meeting, he learned some new things that now make him think that it's a useful thing that we should have. So maybe you can explain what hive is and why you think we need it. So yeah, as Bryce said, I went into the discussions we had about Hive at Varna last week, and I was a Hive skeptic. I understood that it's a data structure, and all data structures have some degree of value, but I couldn't see it in my own work. And after we'd concluded the discussions about Hive, I was gossiping with two people on the committee about the possible use cases. And I actually convinced
然后我会让罗布解释它是什么。但这是一个我一直无法理解其目的的东西，而且我认为罗布最初也是这种感觉，但在上周于瓦尔纳（Varna）举行的委员会会议期间，他了解了一些新东西，现在让他觉得这是一件有用且我们应该拥有的东西。所以也许你可以解释一下 Hive 是什么，以及为什么你认为我们需要它。所以，是的，正如布莱斯所说，我上周在瓦尔纳参与了关于 Hive 的讨论，我曾是一个 Hive 怀疑论者。我理解它是一个数据结构，所有数据结构都有一定程度的价值，但我无法在自己的工作中看到它的价值。在我们结束了关于 Hive 的讨论后，我跟委员会的两个人八卦了可能的用例。我实际上
myself that I want something that approaches that data structure because the things that Hive offers are things that I actually use fairly regularly because the properties of Hive that are the most interesting to me are that it has constant time erasure, reference stability, and also allows you to iterate the elements in any order. It doesn't make any guarantees about the order of the elements. And it occurred to me that every single time that I write any kind of network server, I need exactly this data structure. I have connections that come in. I want some state about that connection. And I want to be able to use that state from an asynchronous operation that can depend on the stability of that reference in memory.
说服了自己，我想要一种接近那个数据结构的东西，因为 Hive 提供的东西正是我经常使用的东西，对我而言 Hive 最有趣的属性是它具有常数时间的擦除、引用稳定性，并且还允许你以任何顺序迭代元素。它对元素的顺序不做任何保证。我突然想到，每当我编写任何类型的网络服务器时，我都精确地需要这个数据结构。我有进来的连接。我想要关于该连接的一些状态。我希望能够从一个异步操作中使用该状态，该操作可以依赖于内存中该引用的稳定性。
But I also want the ability to iterate all of the connections, and I want the ability to erase any of them because they can end at any time without incurring any kind of cost, without any kind of linear complexity, without any allocations or deallocations, and most importantly, without invalidating other references. And this is exactly what Hive gives me. And right now, I use stood list for that. But the problem with stood list is that whenever a connection ends or begins, you have to allocate or deallocate. Now in the grand scheme of things with a TCP server, that doesn't really matter, but we can do better. And I think that's what Hive offers us or at the very least me. Interesting. Well, you know, that is actually a use case that
但我也希望能够迭代所有连接，并且我希望能够擦除其中任何一个连接，因为它们可以随时结束而不会产生任何成本，没有任何线性复杂度，没有任何分配或释放，最重要的是，不会使其他引用失效。这正是 Hive 带给我的东西。目前，我为此使用 stood list。但 stood list 的问题在于，每当连接结束或开始时，你都必须进行分配或释放。现在，从 TCP 服务器的大局来看，这其实并不重要，但我们可以做得更好。我想这就是 Hive 提供给我们的东西，或者至少是对我而言。有趣。好吧，你知道，这确实是一个用例，
maybe changes my, maybe changes my mind a little bit. I'll have to give that a little bit more thought. But that is certainly the sort of use case that I'm not surprised doesn't come up in the sort of work that Connor and I do. Because we are often thinking about sort of pure compute and not things like interactions with network protocols or anything having to do with the OS. And while we do do concurrent programming, we're typically doing parallel programming where we're just coordinating compute work and not where we're, you know, dealing with like asynchronous network programming is very different than the sort of concurrent programming that we do. Yeah, go ahead.
也许改变了我的，也许稍微改变了我的想法。我得对此进行更多思考。但这当然是那种我并不惊讶不会出现在康纳和我所做的那种工作中的用例。因为我们经常考虑的是纯计算，而不是与网络协议的交互或与操作系统有关的任何事情。虽然我们确实做并发编程，但我们通常做的是并行编程，我们只是在协调计算工作，而不是在处理——你知道，异步网络编程与我们做的并发编程非常不同。是的，请继续。
Yeah, and I guess that points something interesting about like kind of the thread that's been woven through this conversation, starting with, you know, the proprietary time series database I worked on, to time series databases, to KDB, and then on to this, is that what I've been immersed in in the last three years, and what the startup that I worked for was concerned with, was giving people really great access to the world's market data. So we had this idea that we needed to give people access to the data, but that access to the data wasn't at the kind of sub microsecond latency that people really associate with HFT, because this was more about doing research or doing something like analytics after a trade or a day or something like that has completed.
是的，我想这指出了贯穿这段对话的一条有趣的线索，从我参与开发的专有时间序列数据库，到时序数据库，到 KDB，然后到这个，那就是我在过去三年中沉浸其中的事情，以及我工作的初创公司所关注的事情，是为人们提供真正出色的途径来访问世界上市场数据。所以我们有这个想法，我们需要让人们访问数据，但对数据的访问并不是 HFT 真正关联的那种亚微秒级延迟，因为这更多的是关于在交易或一天或类似事情完成后进行研究或做一些分析。
What we were really concerned with is very high bandwidth. And so anything that we could do that would level out our performance characteristics was worth it. And so implementing something like Hive to be able to accept incoming connections from our clients and service their queries more quickly and more efficiently would be worth it. It might not lower the absolute latency and the absolute worst case that we experience, but in that case, that wasn't what we were really concerned about. This was more of a big data application. And in my company, we've been seeing the application of a lot of big data techniques to financial market data in a way that belies people's expectations for finance,
我们真正关心的非常高带宽。因此，我们可以做任何能拉平我们性能特征的事情都是值得的。因此，实现像 Hive 这样的东西，以便能够接受来自客户的传入连接并更快速、更高效地为他们的查询提供服务，是值得的。它可能不会降低我们经历的绝对延迟和绝对最坏情况，但在那种情况下，那不是我们真正关心的。这更像是一个大数据应用。在我的公司里，我们看到许多大数据技术被应用到金融市场数据中，这违背了人们对金融的期望，
which is primarily associated with HFT. I got to say your composure during this walk is quite impressive. This might go down as the greatest interview, maybe even podcast of all time on EDSP. Folks, I'm wearing my garment. I'm collecting the nodes. We're walking at a 950 per kilometer pace.
而金融主要与 HFT 相关。我得说你在这段步行过程中的镇定自若真是令人印象深刻。这或许将成为 ADSP 史上最棒的采访，甚至是最棒的播客。各位，我戴着佳明（Garmin）手表。我正在收集节点。我们以每公里 950 的配速行走。
That's like, that's fast folks. And not only are we walking at that pace we're going up bridges we're going down bridges we're walking across rivers and i'm navigating but like we're twisting and turning there's people by us on fact that probably i've seen a couple looks from the locals here maybe tourists being like what is going on here these guys pointing a microphone at each other's mouths this is this is this is history being made right now with Rob Leahy. You are too much, Connor.
这就像是，这很快啊各位。不仅我们以那个配速行走，我们还要上桥、下桥，我们还要过河，我还在导航——就像我们扭来扭去，旁边有人——实际上，我可能看到了本地人的一些眼神，也许还有游客在想：这到底是怎么回事？这两个家伙把麦克风对着彼此的嘴？这，这，这简直是在创造历史，就在此刻，与罗布·利希一起。你太夸张了，康纳。
I'm going to have to cut you off. Okay, cut me off. But let me tell you, folks, this is a big deal. This is history. This podcast is history being made. Rob, I've got to tell you, he's been like this all week. No, not like this. This is history.
我要打断你一下。好吧，打断我吧。但听我说，伙计们，这是一件大事。这是历史。这个播客正在创造历史。罗布，我得告诉你，他一整周都这样。不，不是这样。这是历史。
I mean, we actually made history a few times. That's true. That's true. But this is real. I mean, this is the new greatest way to record podcasts. Walking, talking. Look at this. We got people. They've had too much to drink.
我的意思是，我们确实创造了几次历史。那是真的。那是真的。但这是真的。我的意思是，这是录制播客的全新最佳方式。边走边聊。看这个。我们有人。他们喝得太多了。
We love it. I think, buddy, you may have had too much to drink. Listen, I had a couple glasses of wine, and we love that for us. And honestly, I'm also navigating like a champ. We're 30 seconds away from the Rialto Bridge. Have we ever been like, oh, I took a wrong turn? Absolutely not.
我们喜欢这样。我想，老兄，你可能喝得太多了。听着，我喝了几杯酒，我们很喜欢这种状态。老实说，我也像个冠军一样驾驭着这一切。我们离里亚托桥只有30秒的路程。我们有没有说过，哦，我走错路了？绝对没有。
My navigation skills are unparalleled. Look at that. Here it is, folks. Here's the bridge. Well, does he want to be on the pod? We should get a local. He wanted to be on. We should interview that drunk girl.
我的导航技术是无可比拟的。看那个。这就是，伙计们。桥在这。嗯，他想上播客吗？我们应该找个当地人。他想上。我们应该采访那个喝醉的女孩。
Well, switching topics, because we like to get a little bit of soft topic of background on all of our guests. Rob, so maybe you could tell us a little bit about one of your favorite hobbies, weightlifting. I mean, weightlifting is by far, I would imagine, my favorite hobby, but I don't know that there's much to tell about it. It just consists of doing the heaviest weight you can in the snatch and the clean and jerk, which belies most people's expectations because they hear weightlifting and they just think of lifting weights which is not the case and the other way to disambiguate the sport is to say olympic weightlifting but the fact of the matter is is that i spend altogether too much time on c++ to ever consider going to the olympics so i can't call it that how long
好吧，换个话题，因为我们喜欢了解所有嘉宾的一些轻松背景。罗布，也许你可以跟我们讲讲你最喜欢的爱好之一，举重。我的意思是，举重可以说是，我猜是我最喜欢的爱好，但我不知道关于它有什么好说的。它只包括在抓举以及挺举中尽你所能举起最重的重量，这违背了大多数人的期望，因为他们听到举重时只想到举起哑铃或杠铃，事实并非如此，而澄清这项运动的另一种方式是称之为奥运举重，但事实是，我在C++上花费的时间实在太多了，根本无法考虑去参加奥运会，所以我不能那样称呼它，多长时间
how long have you been lifting weights i I mean, lifting weights, going on eight years, weightlifting, something like seven years. I did weight, you know, just lifting weights as a bodybuilder with a buddy of mine. And then I decided to structure my training more and be a powerlifter. And then I herniated three discs in my back and decided I wanted to really be a weightlifter. You're pushed away, but guess what? We're getting our selfie too, folks. We are. Spin around. Get in there, Rob.
你练举重多久了？我是说，举重，快八年了，举重专项，大约七年。我以前做过，你知道的，和一个朋友一起作为健美运动员举重。然后我决定让我的训练更有条理，成为一名力量举选手。然后我的背部椎间盘突出，决定我真的想成为一名举重运动员。你被挤开了，但你猜怎么着？我们也要自拍照，伙计们。我们会的。转过身去。加入进来，罗布。
This is going down as the best podcast of all time, folks. We're at the top of the Rialto Bridge. How does it feel? It feels wonderful. It is absolutely beautiful here. I have been loving walking through the streets of Venice. It's a pity that tomorrow morning at 8.35 a.m. I have to fly to London and go home
这将成为史上最棒的播客，伙计们。我们在里亚托桥的顶端。感觉怎么样？感觉太棒了。这里绝对美丽。我很喜欢漫步威尼斯街头。遗憾的是，明天早上8点35分我得飞回伦敦回家
for an entirety of three days before I come back to London for CPPNC, which both of these two gentlemen have tried to convince me is perhaps not the wisest thing, but it's... Not good for the trees. All right, all right, all right, all right. But that's the plan.
呆整整三天，然后我又要回伦敦参加CPPNC，这两位绅士都试图劝说我这可能不是最明智的做法，但它……对树木不好。好吧，好吧，好吧，好吧。但这就是计划。
I think we should probably sign off here. Wait, we're not going to sign off yet. Let's ask a couple more. While we're at the top of the Rialto Bridge, we got two Canadians here. Yours truly. Was born and raised Prince George, BC. Studied in Vancouver. Live in Toronto now. We're here with Rob. Give us a little bit, raised Prince George, BC, studied in Vancouver, live in Toronto now.
我想我们大概该在这里收尾了。等等，我们还不要收尾。让我们再问几个。当我们在里亚托桥顶端时，这里有两个加拿大人。本人。出生并在BC省乔治王子城长大。在温哥华求学。现在住在多伦多。我们这里有罗布。跟我们介绍一下，在BC省乔治王子城长大，在温哥华求学，现在住在多伦多。
We're here with Rob. Give us a little bit of your Canadian background, Rob. So my Canadian background doesn't consist of more than one city. I was born, raised, went to all the schools possible in Victoria. And listeners who may be in Victoria may be skeptical and think that I just went to elementary school, middle school, high school, and the University of Victoria. But that is not the case. I went to elementary school, middle school, high school, the University of Victoria, and then Camosun College, and then back to the University of Victoria before I graduated and then left Canada and Victoria on Christmas Day 2016. So you must have really loved—I mean, I've been to Victoria, it's lovely, but you must have really loved Victoria.
我们和罗布在一起。罗布，给我们讲讲你的加拿大背景。所以我的加拿大背景不超过一个城市。我在维多利亚出生、长大并上了所有可能的学校。可能在维多利亚的听众会持怀疑态度，认为我只上过小学、初中、高中和维多利亚大学。但事实并非如此。我上过小学、初中、高中、维多利亚大学，然后是卡莫森学院，然后又回到维多利亚大学，直到我毕业，然后在2016年圣诞节离开加拿大和维多利亚。所以你一定真的很喜欢——我的意思是，我去过维多利亚，那里很可爱，但你一定真的很喜欢维多利亚。
You didn't want to go somewhere else for college? I don't know that going somewhere else for college is something a lot of people in Canada really do, unless they go to McGill or Waterloo, and that wasn't really something that I was interested in. And the University of Victoria has a really great software engineering program particularly, so I got to stay there, save some money, get a great education, and most importantly of all, perhaps, get my iron ring. So it has an actual software engineering program, not just a computer science program. So are you like an actual engineer in the eyes of Canada?
你不想去其他地方上大学吗？我不知道去其他地方上大学是否真的是加拿大很多人会做的事情，除非他们去麦吉尔大学或滑铁卢大学，而那并不是我真正感兴趣的。维多利亚大学的软件工程专业确实非常棒，所以我留在了那里，省了一些钱，受到了很好的教育，最重要的是，也许是拿到了我的铁戒指。所以它有一个真正的软件工程专业，而不仅仅是计算机科学专业。那么在加拿大眼里你算是一个真正的工程师吗？
Depending on what you mean by Canada, then yes. I mean, in Canada, being an engineer can mean one of a variety of things. It can mean that you graduated from an accredited engineering school and got your iron ring, which I did. Or it can mean that you went through the rigors of finding a professional engineer to study under for three years to become a professional engineer, which I did not do because I left for the United States two and a half weeks after I finished my last course. Let's see the ring. I want to see what this ring looks like. All right. It is, in fact, an iron ring.
取决于你所说的加拿大是什么意思，那么是的。我的意思是，在加拿大，成为一名工程师可以意味着多种事情之一。它可以意味着你毕业于获得认证的工程学校并拿到了铁戒指，我做到了。或者它可以意味着你经历了一番磨难，找到了一位专业工程师并在其手下学习三年以成为一名专业工程师，我没有这样做，因为我在完成最后一门课程两周半后就去了美国。让我们看看戒指。我想看看这戒指长什么样。好的。它确实是一枚铁戒指。
I don't have any way to verify its authenticity. I've got a sister with a partner that both have these rings. It's official. I can verify it as a sibling of an engineer. Do you have any other Canadian questions for Rob? Not any Canadian questions. We'll wrap potentially the greatest podcast, technical technology podcast.
我没有任何方法来验证它的真实性。我有一个姐姐，她和一个伴侣都有这种戒指。这是官方的。作为一名工程师的兄弟姐妹，我可以验证这一点。你还有关于罗布的其他加拿大问题吗？没有什么加拿大问题了。我们可能要总结这个最伟大的播客，技术技术播客。
But listen, listen, this was honestly, can you believe it? We just walked 2.1 kilometers at a 10-minute pace. Is that good? And it's very good. It's very good if you're just walking. Most people walk slower than that. We did it.
但是听着，听着，这真的，你能相信吗？我们刚刚以10分钟的配速走了2.1公里。这好吗？这非常好。如果你只是走路的话，这非常好。大多数人走得比这慢。我们做到了。
We recorded a golden content podcast with Rob. So the last thing I have to ask is, Rob, if people want to follow you online, I'm not sure if you're writing papers, but I know you're giving talks at CppCon. You said that you're planning on, I think, proposing three talks for CppCon 2023. You've given six before, if my math checks out. So where can people follow you if they want to go watch your talks, find out more about you've given six before if my math checks out so where can people follow you if they want to go watch your talks find out more about you follow you on the socials i mean on youtube for my talks would be the the best one i i nominally have a
我们和罗布录制了一期高质量内容的播客。所以我必须问的最后一件事是，罗布，如果人们想在网上关注你，我不确定你是否在写论文，但我知道你在CppCon上做演讲。你说你正计划为2023年的CppCon提交三个演讲。如果我的数学没算错的话，你以前做过六次。所以如果人们想去看你的演讲，了解更多关于你的信息，如果我的数学没算错的话，你以前做过六次，所以如果人们想去看你的演讲，了解更多关于你的信息，在社交媒体上关注你，我的意思是，看我的演讲的最佳去处应该是YouTube，我名义上有个
twitter but i haven't posted on there for four or five years and i don't plan on starting which a lot of people in tech would say is unfortunate other than that i i have an instagram and it's just all of the four names that my parents gave me concatenated together. But the only thing that I post on there is me lifting weights and eating food, and so that doesn't really seem like it's very technical in nature. No, no, no. Go ahead and list out the handles. Some of our listeners may be interested. Vittorio might be interested because Vittorio lifts weights.
推特，但我已经四五年没在那里发过东西了，而且我不打算开始，科技界的很多人会说这很不幸。除此之外，我有Instagram，它就是我父母给我取的那四个名字串联在一起。但我唯一在上面发的就是我举重和吃东西，所以这看起来并不是很有技术性。不，不，不。快把用户名列出来。我们的一些听众可能会感兴趣。维托里奥可能会感兴趣，因为维托里奥举重。
We have some other. We've got some people in the C++ community that like to lift. That are into fitness, let's say. I guess if you're into fitness and also into eating, then you can follow me on Instagram at Robert Allen. That's Allen with two A's and two L's. Hennigan Leahy. That's my Instagram handle. And Connor is laughing because that's so comically long.
我们还有其他一些人。C++社区里有一些人喜欢举重。可以说是热爱健身吧。我想如果你热爱健身又热爱吃，那么你可以在Instagram上关注我@Robert Allen。那是两个A和两个L的Allen。Hennigan Leahy。那是我的Instagram用户名。康纳在笑，因为这实在是滑稽地长。
And believe me, I've heard that before from people who try to tag me in stories. They complain bitterly that my Instagram handle is altogether too long. I mean, if they're using some app that doesn't auto-complete that, that's disappointing. You should get three letters into that, and if you follow Rob, that should auto-complete.
相信我，我以前从那些试图在快讯中标记我的人那里听过这话。他们痛苦地抱怨我的Instagram用户名实在太长了。我的意思是，如果他们使用的某个应用没有自动补全功能，那就太令人失望了。你在那上面输入三个字母，如果你关注了罗布，那就应该自动补全。
I mean, what if you follow other Robs, though? There's no other Robs. I do have an Uncle Rob, but he's not on Instagram, so... I can think of, like, three other C++ Robs. I mean i mean this is my favorite one but i can't think of like three other ones well you know too many people anyways thank you rob this was groundbreaking historical stuff the listeners you're gonna get you're gonna be getting hit up on instagram for sure by the fans of bryce the listeners of the pod and I think that this is the last time we will record for the 2023 Slovenia road trip. What a way to end the Slovenia 2023 road trip.
我的意思是，如果你关注了其他罗布呢？没有其他罗布。我确实有一个罗布叔叔，但他不上Instagram，所以……我能想到大约另外三个C++罗布。我的意思是，我的意思是这是我最喜欢的一个，但我能想到另外三个左右好吧，无论如何你认识太多人了，谢谢罗布，这是具有突破性的历史性内容。听众们，你们肯定会被布莱斯的粉丝、播客的听众在Instagram上狂轰滥炸，我想这是我们为2023年斯洛文尼亚公路旅行录制的最后一次了。以这种方式结束2023年斯洛文尼亚公路旅行真是太棒了。
I mean, there's no way we don't do this again in the future at the Nigeria road trip or future road trips without getting this walk and talk pod. I mean, honestly, it's a wrap, folks. Thanks for tuning in. Thanks, Rob, for being a guest. Thanks to him for knocking that bottle. That wasn't any of us.
我的意思是，我们将来在尼日利亚公路旅行或未来的公路旅行中不可能不再次这样做，来获取这种边走边聊的播客。我的意思是，说真的，到此结束了，伙计们。感谢收听。谢谢罗布作为嘉宾。谢谢他撞倒了那个瓶子。那不是我们任何一个人干的。
We're static right now. All right. We're going to go to sleep now. I think I've got to pick Connor to bed. He's not going to go to sleep. We're five kilometers from home. Bryce is going to water taxi home. I'm going to go get some more nodes, and then we'll call it a night.
我们现在一动不动。好了。我们现在要去睡觉了。我想我得送康纳去睡觉。他不会去睡觉的。我们离家有五公里。布莱斯将坐水上出租车回家。我要去获取更多节点，然后我们就收工睡觉。
Okay. All right. All right. Okay. Well, thanks for having me on and on topic for where we are. I will just say, Buona Notte.
好的。好吧。好吧。好吧。嗯，谢谢邀请我来，应景我们现在所在的地方，我只想说，晚安（Buona Notte）。
Buona Notte. Buona Notte. All right. Be sure to check the show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSPthepodcast.com for links to any of the things we mentioned in today's episode,
晚安（Buona Notte）。晚安（Buona Notte）。好的，请务必查看你的播客应用中的节目简介或访问ADSPthepodcast.com，获取我们在今天节目中提到的任何事物的链接，
as well as a GitHub discussion where you can leave questions, comments, or thoughts. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline.
以及可以留下问题、评论或想法的GitHub讨论区。感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢并度过美好的一天。高质量，低产量。这是我们播客的标语。这不是标语。
Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的标语是洒满信息 sprinkles 的混乱。本期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可留下评论。